hi leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne
und da wir uns jetzt schon ein bisschen
kennt dachte ich mir warum lernt ihr
mich nicht mal besser kennen damit so
eine bindung entsteht
deshalb gibt es 20 fakten kurz und knapp
und jetzt geht's los
wie die meisten schon wissen mein name
ist vanessa was aber noch viele nicht
wissen ist dass mein zweiter name maria
ist
ich bin vom sternzeichen jungfrau maria
die ich wohne in der schönsten stadt der
welt und zwar berlin und das schon seit
fast einem jahr schon über ein jahr
krass ja und zwar in der uwg
ich hab die alan tollsten mitbewohner
der welt mein absolutes lieblingsessen
ist lasagne
trotzdem würde ich wenn ich könnte jeden
tag irgendwas mit kohlessen alter falter
ich liebe cool wirklich cool ist für
mich das leckerste auf der welt
blumenkohl rosenkohl weißkohl kohl kohl
ich weiß nicht warum mich dieser
geschmack so an geld aber ich liebe es
ich habe genau drei geschwister und
meine drei geschwister sind echt die
tollsten menschen
man sieht mich fast den ganzen tag mit
einer sonnenbrille rumlaufen und nicht
weil ich eingebildet bin sondern weil
ich grün starhub und deshalb eine starke
lichtempfindlichkeit hat was manchmal
auch anstrengend ist beim drehen aber
ich kriege es hin
meine lieblingsfarbe war schon immer und
wild ist für immer sein
gelb
ich weiß nicht warum arbeits kind hat
sich das so in meinem kopf eingebrannt
das geld einfach meine lieblingsfarbe
ist hierbei mensch ärger dich nicht
immer geld genommen oder bei diesen
ganzen anderen spielfiguren gelb ist
einfach mein ding
meine eltern kommen ursprünglich aus
polen
deshalb spricht meine mutter auch immer
so
die beiden sind vor 25 jahren glaube ich
ja 25 26 nach deutschland gekommen
weshalb ich auch hier geboren wurde und
polnisch sprechen kann ich weil meine
eltern mich jeden sommer wieder nach
polen geschickt haben damit ich meine
sommerferien da verbringe
danke wir waren auch einmal in der
türkei
das war cool aber sonst war meine
sommerferien in polen ich habe es immer
genossen weil da meine ganze familie ist
also oma opa tante onkel und man hat in
polen hat man wirklich viele verwandte
wir haben keine großcousin x- oder
großcousine oder großtanten das bei uns
ist tante onkel kühlen und uns gibt es
nichts anderes finde ich auch gut
außer wenn die fremde menschen
vorgestellt werden als guck mal das ist
deine tante blablabla du denkst ich noch
nie in meinem leben gesehen warum
besteht meine tante warum rede ich so
ich habe als kind nicht gesprochen
ich trage lieber gold als silber ich
weiß ich die leute an immer so eine
präferenz für etwas bei mir ist es gold
geschenkt bob dicker bild gold dicken
armen mal und zeichen eigentlich schon
mein ganzes leben und ich glaube als
kind hat mich nichts mehr begeisterte
jetzt irgendwas zu bilden und irgendwas
großes zu malen oder mir ein kleines
häuschen zu bauen
aber ich habe das gefühl dass ich
irgendwie nie besser werde
also beziehungsweise nie richtig gut
also ich werde niemals irgendwie sagen
können du willst ein porträt von die
haben alles klar kein problem ich kann
so gezeichnet
ich wollte eigentlich schon immer mal
youtube machen also seit ich die ersten
außenseiter videos gesehen habe oder
kultureller natürlich aber irgendwie
habe ich mich nie so richtig getraut ich
meinen dass kennen bestimmt viele die
eigentlich das gefühl haben judith
könnte das auch ja ich möchte auch die
kamera reden und eigentlich möchte auch
videos machen die dann andere leute sich
anschauen und eine community aufbauen
der das gefällt aber man kommt da
irgendwie immer nicht so zu man hat dann
immer mehr ausreden ich hab jetzt auch
die letzten tage ständig eine ausgiebige
habt kein video zu machen ja ich muss
deutscher fahrrad machen ja ich muss
mein zimmer noch saugen und ja
eigentlich muss ich die katze füttern
die ich nicht habe glaube ich müsste mir
erst mal die katze kaufen damit ich sie
füttern gehen kann
ach ja und irgendwann habe ich kelly mal
auf einem event kennengelernt
die kann ich halt schon vor durch ihre
videos und war dann so ein bisschen
durch kleine papers hin zu ihr hin
gekommen ist und mit ihr geredet hat und
gesagt hey ich mag dich voll und sich
friedlich vor sich
und ich würde auch gern youtube machen
und dann hat sie gesagt da macht es doch
einfach was soll denn schief gehen
irgendwie klappt das schon und dann
jetzt die kelly so frömmel standort
gesagt hat ja mach doch einfach ich mir
sagen ja ich mache jetzt einfach hier
ich bin super unordentlich also die
ganze woche über müll ich mein zimmer so
zu damit ich dann am wochenende mich
jedes mal zwingen muss aufzuräumen
weil eigentlich mag ich keine unordnung
nur ich bin unordentlich mein
musikgeschmack es eigentlich so gemischt
dass ich bei gar keiner band sagen kann
jammern die immer für immer ich esse
viel zu viel süß kam also eine tafel
schokolade held by me rechtlich lange
und danach denke ich mir meistens man
warum bist du so viel süßes kennt ihr
das ich mein mann kann nicht die ganze
zeit sogar noch schokolade seien aber
sobald ich eine tafel sehe denk mir 2
3 manchmal glaube ich an einen gott und
manchmal nicht
ich meine schaut euch doch mal das
universum an also das ist so groß und so
unfassbar was da alles so passiert sein
harry fucking potter hat mich bis jetzt
mein ganzes leben begleitet
also er hat mich seit ich neun bin
begleitet aber die zeit davor ist keine
mini erinnern
und ich wünsche mir bis heute nichts
sehnlicher als einmal in hogwarts zu
sein oder einmal mit einem zauberstab
irgendwas zu zaubern
wenn ich euch jetzt verzaubern könnte
meine absolute lieblingsgegner für uns
ich liebe es alle charaktere sind super
die handlung ist klasse die kostüme sind
toll
die schauspieler sind gut die drachen
sind cool
ja ich bin verrückt nach weihnachten
ich liebe einfach alles daran den
weihnachtsmarkt die beleuchtung die deko
des ersten die kekse die kinder die ein
brief an den weihnachtsmann schreiben
und sich was wünschen und es schneit
manchmal und es ist kalt und man
kuschelt sich so zusammen trinken
glühwein und finde das so toll und ich
liebe alles alles was weihnachtlich ist
und ob ihr wollt oder nicht auf meinem
kanal wird man sehen dass weihnachten
ist lebt damit so meine freunde ich
hoffe ihr hattet spaß beim zugucken
links und rechts gibt es meine letzten
videos unten könnt ihr mich immer
natürlich abonnieren wenn ihr lust habt
also wenn nicht und nicht aber wer schon
und würdet euch schon empfehlen
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
video und ich sag euch das mit rotem wie
jedes video und habe in diesem video
viel zu oft offen gesagt marie es ist
deine schuld